dispensary approaches us for an account
we will set them up with a online link
to a portal that will walk them through
all the documentation requirements that
we have and they just upload that
information to the portal and once that
portal has been completed then we would
have one of our compliance specialist go
in and start verifying all the files and
documents after that has been done and
we actually go out and do a site visit
yeah every dispensary and see how
they're conducting their operations yeah
so there's some technological software
that will help monitor all transactions
running through an account and it will
red flag certain transactions that
appear out of the normal cycle what will
help in that regard is the states Act
which is still in the House of
Representatives and that will allow for
any activity that a state has need to be
legal that would be exempt from any kind
of federal prosecution yeah beautiful
thing in the world is just people
showing kindness to each other it's
great when we can live in peace and
harmony with each other and not have
contention and disputes and arguments of
wars just people being
I would say someone's opinion me
contradict yours where's my friend Alan
it's all about your perspective who are
we and what is the nature of this
reality hey everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on we
are on site at the beautiful new West
Summit the cannabis tech conference we
are now than we speaking with Kris call
hi Kris
hi thanks so much for coming on the show
thanks for having me really appreciate
him very excited for this Kris is the
CEO of North Bay Credit Union which is a
full-service credit union and it
supports the cannabis banking as well
all right Chris let's start things off
by learning more about who you are and
how you got in even interested in this
space sure North Bay Credit Union
located up in the North Bay obviously
was written originally started 70 years
ago as an agricultural credit union and
we felt that as cannabis began to emerge
as a greater agricultural crop in our
area that it was a area that we we
should support we've always been about
supporting farmers and agriculture and
so this was the next iteration of that
process and also we wanted to help
address the public safety issue in our
area because it was becoming a greater
issue with more and more cannabis
operators coming into the area and
having no banking alternative and so
there's a lot cash moving around our
city streets and kept in homes and
places that were just unsafe so we
wanted to help address that problem so
then how did this this was 70 years ago
then when this first came up of you know
this is a growing crop of growing
industry and that you know there's too
much cash being stored in homes they're
just being
Brown like you know have it be banked
have it be safer so then what was that
like do you do what are the stories
around that time for for the for the
starting of the North Bay credit union
end well we started out as an
agricultural credit union and supporting
the agriculture in in the area at the
time which was largely fruit orchards
and then migrated to two vineyards so
there's a lot of Vineyards and Winery
operations in our area which we
supported and like I said now over time
in the recent years with the passing of
prop 215 and now prop 64 a lot of that
acreage in our area is being converted
to cannabis operations and we're seeing
a lot of manufacturing facilities
distribution operations come into the
area as a result of that cultivation
activity so it was kind of a natural
natural extension for what we were doing
in agriculture prior to that time so
it's just been in the last two years
really that we've been involved with
cannabis yes okay and then so then what
does that look like like the team having
so much focus on agriculture in terms of
in terms of food crop as well as grapes
for wine and then how does the team re
adjust to something like the new
regulatory frameworks for cannabis yeah
well obviously cannabis is much
different than any other business
because of the federal illegality issue
and so we've had to pivot our operations
to address all of the compliance
concerns we built up a whole department
of compliance specialists to help
monitor all the activity in the accounts
to do all the due diligence work on any
applications that we get in it's our
responsibility to ensure that all the
money being introduced into the
financial system is 100% legal and so we
have to mana
every deposit and make sure that it's
the result of a legal sale and it's just
it's a labor-intensive task which we've
tried to facilitate with some
technological tools but yeah quite a bit
different than any other business that
we work with you normally never have to
monitor deposits to make sure they're a
hundred percent legal that they're
actually real and not being like a lawn
like laundered or what what's like yeah
versus what's the concern with well we
do have a responsibility as a financial
institution to know or customer and make
sure that there's no illicit activities
being conducted in the banking system
and so we do monitor cash transactions
in particular because cash is difficult
to monitor from a paper trail standpoint
and and with cannabis obviously which is
a cash intensive industry there's just
an exponential number of those
transactions as opposed to a regular
business activity so it's it's the money
laundering aspect that requires a lot of
a lot of work and certainly with
cannabis industry being part of the drug
culture and whatnot and there's been
players who've been involved with both
illegal drug distribution as well as the
legal cannabis operations it's our
responsibility to make sure that
anything any money coming into the
system is the result of a legal sale
your responsibility you have to do that
yeah I mean if we're gonna allow the
money to come to our institution we it's
it is our responsibility to make sure
that it's legit we're not law
enforcement
and so we don't aren't probably not held
as to the same standard of going to into
forensic accounting kind of work but
still we're responsible for at least
making an effort to ensure that the
money being deposited with us is as a
legitimate so then how do you leverage
tools to be able to help you with that
process yeah so there's some
technological software that will help
monitor all transactions running through
an account and it will red flag
certain transactions that appear out of
the normal cycle or appear like an
excessive dollar amount or something
that happens on a frequent recurring
basis that looks unusual it's just a
warning signal to us to to go look at
that a little bit more closely yeah okay
so software kind of giving you insights
into patterns that may be of course
harder to see by human eye but also just
then you guys go look at what would you
do then would you go and talk to the
actual account holder about the like
what happens in that scenario yeah
that's when the investigation begins and
so you go talk to the account holder you
ask them to provide documentation for
the transactions you see if if what
they're telling you dives with all else
that you know about the business for
example if you have a dispensary that
you're working with and you know that
there have a certain level of
transactions every month based upon
their normal sales activity and then one
month it spikes way up you want to
understand why that is occurring and
oftentimes there's a legitimate reason
for that and that's fine and what would
be like a legitimate reason maybe it's a
420 sale or something like that
or they've added a new line or a new
product line or something so you know we
we can we just want to understand that
we know why the activity is different
than what we may have expected yeah yeah
okay and then like what is it like then
for also for an institution that begins
to take on dispensaries like what did it
look like a couple years ago and what is
it starting to look like now yeah what
was it huh was it harder you know two
years ago why was it harder and why is
it easier now what came into place well
we've been very selective about who we
choose to bring on as as members of our
credit union and so we're only dealing
with what we feel are the most compliant
most transparent most professional
operators in the industry and those
operators generally have had a culture
of compliance for a long time and so
introducing our banking requirements to
them wasn't a big leap for them it
wasn't a hurdle for them to really have
to deal with because they were already
doing it we have been approached by a
number of dispensaries that are more
johnny-come-lately
newer to the game and they're not used
to the kind of stringent rules and
requirements that we would apply to them
and so if they want to bank with us they
have to really ramp up their compliance
efforts and implement some some things
that are oftentimes costly and an
employee intensive to make sure that
they're doing the things that we want
them to do to be transparent and
compliant with us and the cannabis
industry now has like funnels for credit
unions or for banking like like do I
have like a standardized application to
join like a credit union like yours or
like what would you look like for what
in 240 lick transparency at a dispensary
stuff like that we have a pretty
extensive application process that we've
developed for our own use I can't speak
for what other financial institutions
may do for their purposes but we felt
like to ensure that we're doing
everything properly we've got a really
extensive application process that goes
into their financial history there are
standard operating procedures you know
the information on all of the principles
and their organizational structure their
operating agreements their lease
agreements I mean it's the whole gamut
of documentation that we would require
to go through to make sure everything's
aboveboard and then what percentage do
you guys take in right now of applicants
of total applicants well we're probably
seen we put out a lot of applications
not I would say maybe 60% actually
complete the application process okay I
think some people once they see what's
required will self select out out yeah
yeah yeah it is so and then what out of
those sixty percent I do submit how many
do you guys take in most of them because
if they can complete the hurdle yeah
it's pretty Nate and they have all their
documentation in order and there's no
problems then we have been accepting
most of those accounts very cool and how
many total cannabis accounts do you guys
have now right now we're at about 75
accounts that's pretty cool yeah that's
pretty cool and we've got about another
75 in the pipeline that are waiting to
be approved nice you have a team of
people that have to then go and look
through all of the different submission
milestones and check checkpoints right
and so they're parsing finding making
sure that everything is good and then
damn seventy-five more so then is there
then like when we get okay I have some
questions so so like there's like kind
of like there's there's a count there's
a count there's there's like accounts
count staff or at the credit union that
would then work with like specifically
in terms of like a banker that works
with the cannabis in bribery and so then
they do have to hire more of those to
deal with the 75 that are coming in yeah
we've had to add staff as we've grown so
we have account managers compliance
specialists that work directly with the
accounts and they're the ones that are
constantly interacting with the account
holders to get ongoing information about
financial statements and sales
transactions and those kinds of things
and so as we add more accounts it's
likely that we'll have to continue to
add staff to accommodate that growth and
then do you guys have an easy way to
take the dispensaries a sales report and
look through their like point of sale
system and then you guys can just
analyze that is that usually how right
we actually tie into their point-of-sale
system and so we're getting real-time
feeds from their point of sale system
into our system to monitor the activity
in this that were how what is that
software is that like a plugin that you
had to have specifically designed or
we're using the hyper software which is
a software company serving the cannabis
industry and they're helping on the
compliance side of the operation hyper
yeah is the company's name and so then
hyper designs the ability for like a
credit you need to be able to kind of
plug into a point of sale at a cannabis
dispensary right and then you guys get a
stream of their transactions right and
then you and then hyper also does the
analysis to create the flags if they do
some of that and we also use other
technological tools to analyze it as
well there's anti-money laundering
software the
well runs against the files as well to
double-check the activity what are those
called what are those sufferable we use
there's like very fun we use banker's
toolbox verified banker's toolbox okay
Patriot officer is another patriot
officer whoa
and then what's modes what would you say
is like the most common thing that let's
start with this one what would you say
is the most common thing that the
dispensaries are missing in terms of
needing they want to get into being
banked through a credit union but
they're but they're struggling with I'm
filling out one or two of these check
check boxes that you require what would
you say are those check boxes and how
can you maybe help teach some of the
people that may be interested in that
process to to complete that yeah so one
of the things we're finding with
dispensaries in particular are a couple
of issues first of all there's the issue
of an ATM on-site and we require that
that ATM be not owned by the dispensary
oh it should be owned and operated by a
third party vendor so that the
dispensary doesn't have control over
putting money into the ATM or taking
money out of the ATM ATMs unfortunately
have been used for money laundering
purposes so if we take that whole
responsibility away from the dispensary
than they have no control over it second
area is the payment system used by the
dispensary and we're finding that a lot
of payment dispensaries have been
convinced by various parties that it's
okay to accept credit cards or debit
cards using the Visa or MasterCard brand
and what that's not okay it's not okay
why is that not okay so Visa MasterCard
American Express have all prohibited
purchases of cannabis products on their
rails because
federally illegal product and so they
low and no flexibility for illegal
states no just it's the federal issue so
if a dispensary is taking credit cards
they're probably violating federal laws
and they're probably in jeopardy of well
some sort of action and so we are
working with a number of payment
processing companies that will be allow
them to transact with their customers
the electronic movement of funds and it
won't use the Visa MasterCard rails so
then what are the current solutions for
dispensaries besides cash so there's
like I said these they're called closed
loop systems there's hyper has a payment
a consumer payment product that is just
an app so it's like I'm like a venmo
it's kind of a venmo century yeah
there's others that are used throughout
the industry so it's just a it's a way
for a consumer to have an easy access to
make a purchase without having to pull
out a credit card or a debit card and
then but that hyper would still tight
take into the classical banking accounts
because well like Wells or Bank of
America or whatever they can't chase
they can't like I can make a transaction
at a cannabis store went through hyper
through the bank but just not through
the visa or the MasterCard card right
okay yeah okay yeah so it's just as an
ACH transfer between your account and
the dispensaries account to make that
purchase it's a direct movement of funds
yeah nice
well bypass is the three percent or two
whatever transaction fee as well yeah
yeah okay so that in the ETM are the big
two hurdles right now that you're seeing
yeah those are two areas that we look at
very carefully when evaluating them
count
yeah so dispensary literally has they
have to have an ATM on-site because yeah
the people have to get cash a lot of the
time and so then they have to have a
third party then operating to be able to
be banked by something like you guys
yeah okay where they also have to go
through a process of educating their
customers as they come through the door
that they would need to use a platform
like hyper instead of their card or
bring cash every time right yeah the
educational piece is really interesting
in this as well because like you want to
onboard people that want the health
wellness to all these other benefits
that come from it but you want it to be
frictionless like you don't want to
create people to turn around and say
this is too saturated with friction yeah
you don't wanna make it so difficult
that people just walk away from it yeah
and then ok now let's now let's talk
about on the most on the most common
instances with the the plague the flake
points that are called by hyper in the
use of Patriot there's like all these
other parsers analyzers of the of the of
the transactions that are happening
flags were for you gave us some examples
are there like big spikes maybe in a in
a day or big sale or whatever it may be
what are the other common ones and how
do you deal with you know with them is
it like the account manager that goes
and talks to them and then they learn
and they say approved or if they
disapprove because the story isn't
adequate then like what would be a next
step yeah I guess you know there's a
variety of situations that would cause
us to launch an investigation of some
type it could be a return of product if
you're
or bad product that has to be disposed
of that's not creating revenue when you
know the inventory movement doesn't
match up with the sales product as in
product was purchased as they thought it
was yeah and it proved did not be good
yeah so we've rented the situation when
a product was purchased from a
distributor for example that wasn't
labeled properly and therefore couldn't
be sold so it had to be returned to the
distributor or disposed of and so
there's this disconnect between what was
put out for purchase of inventory versus
what was actually sold and that's the
kind of analysis that we would do to
make sure that everything makes sense in
terms of what the operation that we're
dealing with if there's a gap in
something that we would normally expect
to happen then we start asking the
questions where it is where do you see
efficiencies to be made like is there a
streamlining of the like credit union
application process that can happen
where dispensaries can maybe begin like
applying you know by submitting like
online and just check marking through
and then you guys maybe can automate
some of the processes of viewing what
they've you know like where do you see
some of the efficiencies in the future
of software helping out streamlining
more yeah we've actually already got the
online application down whenever a
application at a dispensary approaches
us for an account we will set them up
with a online link to a portal that will
walk them through all the documentation
requirements that we have and they just
upload that information to the portal
and once that pore
has been completed then we would have
one of our compliance specialists go in
and start verifying all the the files
and the documents and then after that
has been done then we actually go out
and do a site visit yeah every
dispensary and see how they're
conducting their operations live yeah
yeah and then like there's there's a lot
of things changing with banking and
regulations around cannabis do you see
some things that likes the state level
can do to make it better for banks to
work with the cannabis industry well the
state state of California has actually
been pretty good to work with because
we're a cannabis friendly state overall
the banking regulators that we have to
deal with are still in need of some
education about how the industry works
and what we face as financial
institutions serving that industry I
think there's still some misconceptions
about some things that go on that
they're catching up and I think they're
becoming more knowledgeable about the
industry and how banking works with the
industry but the real problem Allen as
well as at the federal level and getting
the federal regulators to allow the
banking activities to proceed without
interference and I think that's gonna
take a while if the safe Banking Act
certainly a big step forward but you're
not gonna see a lot of banks or credit
unions jump into this market until
cannabis is D scheduled eyes so
that'll be a while okay so at the
federal level we have this this safe act
that was moved through that is kind of
slowly enabling the banking of the
emerging market but it's kind of just
the baby stuff yeah okay and then we
need the bigger steps and the bigger
steps what would be like the second and
third bigger steps to open up the thank
you
so the SAFE Act will remove will
prohibit a banking estate banking
regulator from taking punitive actions
against a financial institution
conducting cannabis operations it does
not remove federal ability to come in
and prosecute or investigate a financial
institution for money laundering
activities from a federal standpoint
yeah what will help in that regard is
the states Act which is still in the
House of Representatives and that will
allow for any activity that a state has
deemed to be legal that would be exempt
from any kind of federal prosecution so
if that were to pass that would
certainly help things as well but the
motherlode of of where this is all going
to turn around is when cannabis is d
schedule d schedule i's does a class 1
drug okay yeah
yeah let's get there yeah yeah let's get
there and also distributing the the
fruits of the democratization of the
cannabis is critical cannabis comes in
as a merging market distributing the
fruits widely very important
maybe then another question that I that
I should ask is around the use of again
another thing that's an emerging market
that's being stacked into this emerging
market cryptocurrency decentralization
technology do you feel like how is that
intermingling with transactions at
dispensaries you know we've seen some
some payment platforms emerge recently
that used cryptocurrency is there a tool
of exchange
we've been hesitant to do much with
those companies because you're combining
really two high risk activities into a
single transaction and it it's just it's
a lot to take on there's so much
compliance work and oversight that has
to go on with just cannabis activities
that we don't need the additional
complexity that arises when you throw in
a cryptocurrency angle to it so I mean
over time I think that that's probably
going to grow as an accepted means of
transaction but I don't think that's
gonna happen in the near near term and
we're gonna work our way into that
slowly okay yeah yeah see how it is is
like a double risk yeah yeah okay okay
so that's another one of those things
too hopefully
get around the world faster and safer so
that we can then be able to more swiftly
use it within cannabis and so many other
important transactions that we want to
make
there's over overall future of just
cannabis dispensaries being banked do
you see cannabis dispensaries always
selecting to be Bank do they always have
to be banked what are alternative
options for them ideally there would be
banked I mean it's hard to pay your
bills it's hard to pay your employees if
you can't write a check you know if
you're always doing in cash you're
always gonna have this issue of storing
the cash counting the cash keeping your
operation safe you know from any kind of
criminal activity so ideally more
cannabis operators would find banking
solutions and we could remove that cash
handling component from from their
activities just like any other business
that operates on a mostly electronic
currency basis so it's difficult until
more banks start getting into that space
we can only take on so many accounts as
a small credit union so we're gonna need
other players to join us in this effort
and then do you see some of the the
protocols that you've laid down us as
frameworks for dispensaries to come on
to your credit union do you see are
there any enquiries happening from
Colorado or Washington or other states
where they reach out and they ask for
those frameworks and or is there some
sharing going on of the protocols to
onboard dispensaries to banks well we
get approached fairly frequently by
banks or credit unions that want
start a cannabis program and they want
to know what our experience has been and
how we do it and what our compliance
team looks like and what the procedures
are and I'm happy to share information
with them but it's a it's not something
that you do overnight I mean it's a very
it's a month-long if not a year-long
process to just get the infrastructure
in place to start taking on accounts we
we followed sort of the template of a
credit union partner Colorado Credit
Union in Colorado they were really the
first in this area and kind of the
leader in that regard
so we followed what they did and then
built our own program here in California
according to the California market and
California state laws around cannabis
seems like hopefully in the future we'll
be able to do things like create the
this is the similar frameworks that were
brought from Colorado to here that are
then now being brought on to so many
other banking institutions that want to
take on cannabis industry like if we can
do things like help them get the
greatest amount of signal from the
protocols and implement them quickly
then they can then bring on the cannabis
dispensaries themselves faster so then
so there's also in addition dispensaries
you guys take on like farmers as well
yeah we do the whole supply chain of
cultivators manufacturers distributors
delivery services ancillary accounts
like packagers or dam even a packager
yeah a packager can be banked cuz they
bank you because their packaging
cannabis diet wow that's so crazy and
they have to like go get their own
license for the packaging I don't have
to be licensed if you're not plant
touching you don't need to be licensed
but if you're accepting revenue from a
cannabis operation it's very difficult
to find a banking relationship
because banks don't want to have any
thing to do with cannabis money yeah
yeah whoa okay so packagers are banked
by you
farmers are distributors so like the the
last mile delivery companies banks by
you mm-hmm interesting yeah we've had
some on our show so then they must be
either working in complete cash or bank
by someone like you guys how do you guys
how do you guys figure out the analytics
on the side of yeah on the last mile on
the drivers or on the these are so this
this is software like hyper help with
all of those the farmers and the
packagers you can it can do all of those
it can analyze all those well there's
certain elements that are gonna apply to
all license types compliance elements
and then there's nuances for each
license type that have to be considered
individually so obviously when you're
doing like with a consumer and a retail
setting like a dispensary it's a
different set of compliance analytics
then if you're just growing the product
as a cultivator and you're not dealing
with any consumers so we have to
consider those differences and we've
incorporated those into our internal
procedures like getting one big
transaction of like a hundred thousand
bucks for product right every couple of
months or whatever right versus the
couple minutes right a buy at a store
stuff like yeah interesting seems like
also the more that the data silos open
up and are able to talk to each other
than like your information about a
certain you know farmer and the way that
they grow and then and distribute can
also help other banking institutions
better understand their
growers and in their dispensary so like
the more that your data silos can talk
to each other the more insights you can
see from each other
yeah it creates a domino effect too
because the more you can service the
entire supply chain you're you're able
to remove the cash that would go all the
way from the manufacturer who's paying
the cultivator and the distributor who's
paying the manufacturer and the retailer
who's paying the distributor if you're
banking all of those then it's all it's
all visible interbank transfer of funds
in her bank and you don't have to deal
with the cash payments so that's that's
the advantage of digital you're just
moving it in their accounts then yeah
yeah yeah yeah which is how it should be
there shouldn't be the need to move cash
that's why this stuff's really that's
why this stuff's really interesting just
just be able to send you a bit of crypto
and you know just be a digital bit you
know just change those little bits in
the in the accounts yeah yeah that's
fascinating that's a really interesting
part of our future that yeah that I hope
that we can get to and also just move
away from move away from Fiat and also
regardless money is something that is
just a shared collective hallucination
and one that's at least more
decentralized one that's a more in the
power of people seems to be something
that we're all excited to move towards
so there are two questions that we like
asking that are you know that are that
we ask on every show that are different
than what we normally talk about are
with our guests topic wise the first
question is do you think we're in a
simulation that's an interesting thought
sometimes I wonder sometimes life is too
strange to think that it's a occurring
without some sort of manipulation
somewhere yeah but in design yeah yeah
yeah
although I don't know if we're in the
matrix I want to go that far hahaha and
the other question is what do you think
is the most beautiful thing in the world
you know beautiful thing in the world is
just people showing kindness to each
other it's great when we can live in
peace and harmony with each other and
not have contention and disputes and
arguments and Wars so just people being
kind I would say yeah thanks for us
thank you so much for your show and
teaching us about this has been so
interesting learning yeah King thanks
man thank you glad you had a good time
thanks everyone for tuning in we'd
greatly appreciate it we'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below in
the episode let us know what you're
thinking also check out the links in the
bio below to Chris's work check out the
links in the bio to the North Bay credit
union as well check that out also have
more conversations about that have more
conversations about new West Summit as
well check those links out in the bio
and also support the artists the
entrepreneurs the organization's leaders
around the world in your communities
that you believe in you can support us
and our show our links are below and go
and build the future everyone manifest
your dreams into the world you love you
very much thanks for tuning in and we
will see you soon peace that's a wrap
good job that was very lame there's so
much complex nuanced - it's crazy
yeah it's crazy but it's so interesting
yeah that's why I'm getting so many
requests to do these kinds of things
because not many people really know
about all this stuff
[Music]
you
[Music]